we add this story as an update China
largest complaint after Biden says U.S
could U.S would defend Taiwan in a
Chinese invasion so this is it I'm going
to say this first and foremost the White
House has gone Rogue now I know hold on
we said a long segment talking about how
Biden's brain is completely broken
and so you would assume the White House
must do something to stop a Mad King
right you know like uh was it Robert
Baratheon he was the one who slayed the
no no I'm sorry that's not true that was
um it was uh Lannister oh yeah
and so uh here we have Joe Biden who I
don't think mad is the right word what's
the right word the Daft see the the
deluded
the dotted King and so um the White
House is basically
intervening and rejecting and denying
the stated policies of the
commander-in-chief now here's what I'm
gonna say the executive branch has gone
completely Rogue I I I firmly believe
that I was thinking about this day
because Joe Biden has now said four
times
it is the U.S policy four times to
militarily defend Taiwan and every time
he does the White House goes actually
that's not true and it's like well I
don't know who the spokesperson is but
the commander-in-chief just went to a
press conference in Tokyo and said we
will and the Pres the president
Commander in Chief just went in 60
minutes and said this is our policy yeah
and when Scott Paoli said you sang the
US Army would defend he goes yes
definitively when the President says it
the duly elected commander-in-chief that
is the policy he sets the policy the
White House intervened and says no it
isn't the doj intervenes they do what
they want look at Donald Trump this has
been happening under Trump and Biden
plain as they the executive branch has
gone Rogue under Donald Trump they lied
to him about the number of troops in
Syria rejecting his orders to get our
troops out under Joe Biden he is stating
definitively over and over again our
policies our position on Putin no they
said it's not true our position on
Taiwan no it's not true if the president
says it you listen who is the person
under Trump and now under Biden who are
the people who are outright saying we
will not listen to the
commander-in-chief yeah no it's it's
more than more than one look at Deborah
Burks right when she was going back to
covid stuff and in her book she talks
about how yeah I wouldn't give Trump
those numbers yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
share that data like I wasn't going to
share it with them because it would have
screwed everything up so she made the
decision that I don't have to to tell
the president so he can make decisions
I'm more powerful than the president and
I think at every policy issue there's
someone who calls those shots but the
clean house has to be huge but there's
no coincidence especially when you look
at the presidency when it changes from
democratic to Republican the National
Security State American foreign policy
usually stays the same it's usually very
hawkish it's very neoconservative it's
very pro-war and it's very
pro-globalization pro-imf World Bank
policies that of course are are
spreading all this globalization around
the world what I think is happening here
if I could put on my conspiratorial hat
is that they literally wheel bite it in
into an interview which he does very few
of and then they wheel them off after
they take them off all the drugs they
put them at a table just like a Fisher
Price table and it has a button it has a
phone but none of it actually works and
there's people behind the scenes truly
calling the shots just like they do in
almost every other presidency and and
Biden and legitimately legitimately
could be pressing the the nuke button
could be calling people talking to
people but it's all make pretend it's
all it's all make believe it's not real
and the people truly calling the shots
are people who have more power than the
president of the United States and they
probably meet in private organize and
and set policies that of course we've
been following for many decades now that
always go unquestioned that every
president promises to change when he's
going to become president every
president when he runs on that campaign
Trail says I'm going to stop the wars
I'm going to stop the spying I'm going
to bring back American Liberties I'm
going to bring back America and none of
them are able to do it I love the idea
of this is a skit for you Tim I love the
idea of president with his fake phone
his fake buttons that when he calls and
he's like get me the president of France
and it's like do your French accent
French accent like a wee Michelle
president
give me Germany it's like who does
German who does German uh this is the
German Prime Minister and she's like
this one guy here
give me give me the president of Germany
and he's like
this is President of Germany why do you
sound Russian Russian uh regarding
whether or not assistant tell me the
president of the Congo
what other evidence do you need than the
current president of the United States
to understand that there's a shadowy
secretive group really callings the
things behind the scenes what other
evidence do you need is that even a
secret it's not a secret under Donald
Trump they outright lied and blocked him
from doing the things he ordered yeah if
I went on CBS as the president had made
a statement about my political agenda
and then someone in my Administration
countered came out and secretly counted
I'd fire them that that moment you're
fired seriously it's why Trump said he
was going to release the the JFK
documents he didn't do it he couldn't do
it because there was someone above him
said no you're not it's one of the
reasons why I love
um you say yeah what you said blizzard
person yeah no I didn't say yeah to that
but one of the things that one of the
reasons the person I'm most excited
about running profits right now is uh uh
running in in Washington state Dan
Crenshaw but one of the things that got
him to run was that his wife was in
Syria when they lied about the numbers
I'm sorry Dan Crenshaw I'm like oh my
gosh
one is
um wasn't has Joe kid ever been on uh
yes yeah I wasn't on that show right and
that's like his his wife was one of the
ones who died because they lied to him
when Trump was like what's going on in
Syria and they were like let's just tell
him this tell him this tell him this
they lie and so Joe Ken is like you got
you guys killed my wife because you're
you're more powerful than president
Trump maybe Bill Gates By the way is
bragging today Bill Gates came out on
MSNBC they were playing a video clip of
him and he says you know the president
of the United States Donald Trump at the
time came to me he asked to be an
advisor I said no and then Donald Trump
asked me if if I needed to do uh
independent Commission on the effects of
vaccines Bill Gates says he told him to
absolutely not to do it not to do it
because it was a quote dead end and the
president of the United States listened
to him and listened to the advice of
Bill Gates and didn't do a commission
and investigation into what's really
happening right now and now the data is
still being hidden away from everyone
with the FDA hiding information about
what actually happened and transpired
within the last few years which is
absolutely crazy yeah and and it's got
to be all financially going back to this
issue of the stocks it's all Financial
incentives it's not just because people
like I believe so passionately about
Syria that I'm gonna lie about the data
it's like no like you're doing this
because you have ulterior motives we've
got
we call it a cult but it's Mass
formation psychosis yeah well here I'm
looking at the definition of Madness uh
a state of severe mental illness not
non-technical so you could argue that
Biden's in a state of Madness right now
that he's the Mad president uh or a mad
president believe Behavior thinking that
is very foolish or dangerous yeah but
saying that we're going to invade Taiwan
when apparently the the White House's
statement is invaded right right defend
Taiwan send troops there against the
will of the people
um who knows Taiwan wants us if they
want us then it wouldn't be an invasion
but if they didn't ask for it we went
there to defend democracy then it would
technically be a counter Invasion unless
you think it is China then we are
invading uh and so apparently the policy
is we're not going to mention it but he
mentioned it anyway so that's a state of
foolish or dangerous thinking I don't
know well look look the the problem here
is
I think a lot of people recognized that
it was dangerous what Biden said that
he's risking World War I think The
Hodgetwins said Grandpa's about to get
us into World War III and I thought
about it I'm like yeah but Trump had
that phone call where he was like they
thought we would nuke them if they took
uh Russia if Russia took Ukraine or
China took Taiwan and he's like I don't
know they believed me but maybe five
percent so it was enough and I'm like
that's that's crazy and scary but see
that's Trump being like that level of
aggression so my issue here is not that
Joe Biden said we will defend Taiwan I
actually can respect that because when
he was asked about it twice he goes yes
like definitively no question my problem
is somebody in the White House is
defying him and trying to assert some
kind of authority over his stated policy
positions and is super pro China this
entire White House is and and I always
have to go back to environmental issues
but if you really want to defend Taiwan
so sincerely from an invasion of China
then you would be seeking policies that
weaken China and yet we're spending 380
six billion dollars to buy solar panels
and wind turbines from China and lithium
battery and lithium exactly our whole
policy is pro-china and we gave them
Afghanistan we literally gave up them a
silver platter and all the raw minerals
as soon as the United States military
left the Chinese uh engineers and the
Chinese companies came right in and now
we're going to be going through a Green
Revolution going to be energy
independent we're not going to be
independent we're just buying lithium
batteries from China China that of
course has record CO2 emissions they're
doing this to help the environment the
environment is going to be screwed over
even more allegedly according to their
own and data and but but what's going to
change is we're going to be investing in
China and China is going to be
controlling our energy sector which is
crazy and we're going to be yeah yeah
and we're removing tariffs from China
yeah if we move away from fossil fuels
and we go towards lithium batteries and
solar panels China essentially will have
a control on the market yeah they don't
have it yet because of fossil fuels uh
the petrol dollar has the control on the
market but China will have a huge
control thanks for the plug Elon also
hasn't mentioned lithium is not the
future of battery power he knows that as
well I don't have a story pulled up
about it graphene maybe yeah I think he
actually has recently been looking into
graphing batteries oh wow yeah graphy
yeah Graphics power of the future with
graphene I was I was when I was in the
Texas doing this youth conference
because there were a bunch of rural
folks on that level American we talked
about the Ford F-150 the lightning one
and I I just told them about how in a
Wall Street Journal guy was was driving
it with an empty two-horse trailer and
after 100 miles the battery was dead and
I was like how many of You Haul 15.
electric fat the electric one empty
two-horse trailer a hundred miles dead
and I was like how many of You Haul
fifteen thousand twenty thousand pounds
of cattle on a weekly basis and so you
know the so of course Elon knows the
future of lithium is it doesn't have the
horsepower it doesn't have the strength
it doesn't that's why you know and it's
cool and that's why little duracells are
great and that's why batteries in your
iPhones are great but to compare just
the the the potential energy of what is
needed to power elevators and to power
airplanes you know uh just it's well
it's nonsensical and it's moving towards
a pathway where of course they will be
limiting people's movement and that is
the end game towards the Green
Revolution that we're going towards it's
it's it's the thing behind the screen
it's behind the cover that's essentially
where we're heading towards yeah exactly
so there's there's the story that I'm
seeing going around they're saying that
uh Ram's gonna drop the EcoDiesel V6 or
whatever
so a lot of people are it's 33 miles to
per gallon it's the ram turbo diesel
three liter v6 or whatever A lot of
people are bringing this up because you
know Ram is going to be moving forward
like an electric truck or some sort but
you were just talking about how it went
100 miles and then died it was dead yeah
so I I mean if you need to haul anything
of weight you're as of now the electric
vehicles can't make it they may
revolutionize electric cars and electric
trucks someday and the future is bright
we may get there but the fact of the
matter is we're not there so if you
think I'm just going to get my electric
truck and do what I do with my fossil
fuel truck you're kidding yourself you
can't haul substantial weight the same
reason why when they said we finally got
this airplane to to fly from JFK to
France on battery power or on on solar
panels I was like yeah it was unmanned
and it had nothing but batteries it was
it was it was it was a a toy you know
you just can't compete with the actual
energy released from the hydrocarbons of
fossil fuels so they're nuclear could
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there